if you look at that polygamous societies
one of the things that they see that's
prevalent is there's a lot of like grape
there's a lot of crime because
um in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women which leaves the
other men to revolt and cause problems
so monogamy is actually beneficial to
society it keeps women safe it makes the
society by enlarged more better nuclear
family homes lead to less um
traumatic experiences for children so
you can see there's a lot of benefits
through marriage um so yeah there's
all right but you actually didn't really
answer the question like why you want to
get mad you why you want to again it's a
beautiful thing
okay you already said that beautiful yes
it puts your kid in every single
advantage over that being in a situation
where you're not married yes so why like
what so it's more beneficial for kids
don't have children now right no it will
be beneficial uh it will be yeah yeah
yeah so now the point i was trying to
get is
if like if you have a reason for why you
want to get married
and you believe in
marriage and the vows that you've made
whether it's to god or wherever then why
would you then
go against those vows and cheat and then
it's for some reason it's okay first of
all i haven't cheated no no i'm just
because the guys have left and they were
here before i'm gonna ask them no i hear
what you're saying but
i hear what you're trying to do i hate
what you're trying to say but you have
to remember and we've mentioned this
before that although marriage is what
sought after and it's more beneficial
for our offspring
one the reason i seek marriage is
because
it's better for my kids to be raised in
a nuclear family
but
it's still it's
marriage is still not my biological
imperative i have to sacrifice elements
of my biological being
to conform to the female standard if i
had my way i'd have my woman that i love
and this woman that just chopped him out
again if i had my way but to conform to
the social standards of society
i try to be in a monogamous situation i
don't aspire to be a man that cheats
however anything that hasn't happened
it's just a prediction of the future
what i'm saying and i think most men
will put it that way so i'm just saying
this look if you've got a good man and
he steps out once in like once or twice
in 40 years
listen the grass isn't green until you
water it the grass isn't green on the
other side so i think that's the thing
that women have to recognize does that
work both ways of course not yeah
because men can love multiple women at
the same time where women can only love
my man and if she's cheated if she's
cheating on you you don't love him no
but you you use an example yeah could
you just walk out now
see a guy attracted to you and say
listen go [ __ ] me in the corner right
now could you do that so that's could
you could you do that for me personally
i couldn't most women would most women
couldn't that's my plan yeah so most
people don't want to behave like that
you see a man if he sees a girl he's
attracted to you i will bang you in the
bush
i'll bang in a street corner i bang in
the yard it don't matter it is what it
is but that's the that's the fundamental
difference so so why it can't be flipped
around is because it takes more for you
to allow someone in whereas for a man
it's like taking a piss so that's why
it's different but why is it except no i
don't think you get one from the state
why is he accepted no because if if a
woman cheats here there's there's a
reason behind why she's cheating of
course so then why is it that if she
cheats you can't just accept it it's
because it goes beyond sex there's the
emotions involved that for a woman to
let a guy in there's a process it's
premeditated it's never just a slip up
for a man it's literally like i wasn't
using my head and i had a nut to bust
and that's that's all it is but for you
it goes further than that okay but what
if it was a slip up if it was a girl
you should just have a one night stand
that's not a slipper i might bend you
over and blasting your back yeah she's
on holiday that's premeditated you've
got that holiday i want wanting to [ __ ]
her brother
if you love a man if you love a man
you're not looking
if you really love a man you're not
you're not looking at anyone else you
only see him listen to what i'm saying i
said if you are in a situation where
you're married and your woman slipped up
and just one time she slept to someone
just on holiday you know what once do
you know why you take her i see you're
doing here and
you're you're trying to use the
exception to that it's not to me no
there is because most women wouldn't
behave most women aren't slipping up
like giving a scenario in that scenario
i'd like to think but it could never
happen i would just fall and die if i
hear that
my immune system will shut down i'll
just get covered and i'll pass away okay
so would you take her back
i could not i couldn't because you know
what by look by by by holistically
that's not how women behave so how am i
supposed to assume that this is just a
slip up and not something more how how
can i make that i'm telling i'm telling
you it's not
giving you a situation no and i hate
what your situation is saying but i'm
saying as a man
i can't assume that that is the case the
assumption that the answer is no you
wouldn't take it
100 because you know
you because you should know that me
slipping up is literally just slipping
up
you letting a man in
it's not it's not you said it yourself
you couldn't just let a man slip into
your tongue like that i said me
personally i'm most women dating you i'm
always giving you a situation but if you
was dating me you can't slip up like
that i'm sorry i'm just giving you a
secret
i'm saying i'm giving you an actual
scenario where she slipped up she went
on holiday she had a hot girl oh yeah
and then she just had a bit too much to
drink one thing led to another she just
one night stand oh i didn't it meant
nothing it was just a slipper but i
don't care i'm saying and then would you
take her back
can i just say that women can i just say
that we're men she right when men she
it got no it's just it got nothing to do
with life i understand that when women
oh then when men cheat it's a one-off
when women cheat the relationship is
finished i just can't
explain everything that you've i agree
and 100 what i'm trying to say is that
how many women
are there if a woman cheats
she knows that the relationship is
finished
nine times out of ten if the woman
cheats that's the end of it that's the
end of her relationship that's true but
if a man cheats
it's not the end or to put it as my mum
will say it
men have all their bits on the outside
so they can fling it around everywhere
god hid the women's away because it's
hard to find internals so if you're
gonna go and give it away like that
there's a lot to go through for a man to
get to you internally rather just on the
outside because women are the
gatekeepers of sex but even more but
even more than that you have to think
but the point guys is like it's not
about the man which is coming back and
every time we know that he's probably
gonna sleep around and come back home
the point is what about us like how do
we do you think that not actually you
know
has an impact on your marriage do you
think she's gonna be fine
no knowing that you actually eat other
okay
are you sleeping next to me i'm not
saying they wouldn't paint you yeah so
and so you actually prefer like yeah and
do you think they're good because
men and women aren't the same yeah
by my face i know i know but you're
making everything about you like we
stop over talking me again again stop
over talking me stop over talking me no
no no no stop stop i'll you can go after
i'm done okay
it men and women aren't the same and so
a man can have sex with a hole in the
wall they don't care a woman a woman if
she sleeps with some a man he has to be
someone we are not sleeping with bums
out there unless he looks like michael b
jordan that is it i get that but again
like i asked everyone individually would
you get married and why i've asked him
individually would you take a woman back
if she slipped up and it was just a
one-and-done thing and it was michael b
jordan and it was like she had a chance
to would you take her back no
no no but but if you did it and you
slept with a random whatever she can
take you back
they're random women aren't going to
sleep with a random american i'm not
saying a woman i'm saying you as
yourself i'm asking as an individual not
generalizing okay so
should a woman take a man back if he
cheats no she shouldn't does she yes
that is not our choice
as we are saying men and women are
different if you speak to women i've
spoken to a lot of women yeah and when
they say to me oh um my relationship
ended because my man was cheating yeah
the first thing i say to them is what
did he cheat once and then you left and
they said no he was cheating is never he
cheated it's always he was cheating
which meant this dude has decided he is
going to continue
sleeping with other women but when did
she find out it was women it doesn't
find that one and then it was oh
no no no my point is you are not going
to go out and find a woman who says
i went i was going out with this dude he
cheated on me once and i left
you don't it doesn't happen if women if
women don't like being she didn't why
did they pick the guys that cheated
exactly but even so yeah even so
on your point yeah
if i was to take this woman back do you
think she'll ever respect me so she's
gonna go she's gonna go sit in the next
man's face for banter
one was a look it was a man no no no no
if if you because you have to remember a
lot of relationships are predicated on
on respect yeah
if you've lost that respect for me
enough to step out
it's gone because you have to think
about in relationships the only time the
relationship's really done is when the
woman says it's done
the man can say he's done and come back
a week later babes listen i'm sorry he's
dick's heart he wants to do something
you see when a woman says she's done
there's no return end of end of so for a
woman to do that
imagine it's done
it's saying and for a man the most
egregious crime you can commit is is
disloyalty there's no there's no bigger
crime
may i come back to your point you said
uh i never eat about you know our women
say uh he cheated once
yeah you're right because man doesn't
cheat one if it's if it's cheat once
we're gonna come back to again again
again so man doesn't cheat once in a
while or once in his life it just if it
is going there it gonna come back he's
walking out okay
do you ever ask why he cheated
yeah because they know enough
a lot of times like girls don't give
their guys sex and are confused when
he's not trust me trust me i've been
there
okay okay 25 of marriages are six
months